oh you were actually born on the fourth
of July I was that's correct my birthday
is come is here it's now I'm having a
birthday oh the best part about fourth
of July to us is clearly getting your
friends together going to a barbecuing
yeah but you know what there's no reason
why you can't just wired up your
barbecue right and use like generous
amounts of check to you'll pull off like
the perfect bar to impress all your
friends what we did is we found one of
the best portable barbecues you can that
money can buy this is the solar infrared
portable grill and what it is and what's
cool about it is that it's an infrared
barbecue so rather yes yes what yes
infrared a wavelength of light that we
can't see ya know this thing is so hot
it's it literally would burn your face
if you put your face down on it right
well I think a normal barbecue do that
totally however a normal barbecue cannot
output 14,000 14,000 btus that is way
what the bra who I can't believe you to
ask me that question it is a british
thermal unit on july for it on july 4th
is now we have the third amendment so
those British are not quartered in our
houses now fell away why don't we call
them us to use oh and the way it works
it is that's really cool is that it has
a ceramic tile that is underneath and
then the propane basically ignites heats
up that and then it gets infrared rays
that go direct into the meat as opposed
to a standard convection type heating
device which basically just heats the
air around it okay so though because
they cook things more efficiently
they're essentially in three minutes
this grill turn it on fire it up and
it's ready to go and from there it'll
cook quicker than the standard so in
like 10 minutes you can have a steak
ready to go so for somebody who's not
really used to cooking on a barbecue
like this how would you really know when
your meat is cooked what I do it
typically is I cut into the stick and
you have to look at the inside but then
you want to bring somebody a stick
that's been cut into and they just think
you're a weirdo right now there's an
analog thing you can do by putting your
thumb and forefinger together that
indicates that a meat is rare if you put
it to right right there with your middle
finger oh yeah everything you're about
your about well yeah
I think people will think it's a little
weird when I start touching it also a
carbecue it's not scientific it's not at
all science right so that's why Oregon
Scientific company has come up with this
and this and this is a wireless meat
thermometer you can take that probe you
stick it in your meat okay okay so you
have this device right here now what
this does is this wirelessly interfaces
with this uh this hub can go within 100
feet of your of your meat that's great
you can leave your meat cooking and then
that thing will tell you if it's done
and yeah and then you can you can select
rare medium and well done on this guy so
it'll give you alerts on the temperature
meat so if you have one person wants to
steak rare you can put in our rare if
you want if one person wants a tall
medium you can put it on medium but what
if I'm not eating red meat what if I
just want to cook some fish or what if
I'm cooking like a weenie it has setting
for a beef lamb veal hamburger pork
turkey chicken and fish he's really
tasty hot dog I've ever had yeah
Oh soon that 33333 make sure to carry
the one cuz 2009 yes 233 years 2009
minus nineteen seventy six plus three
carry the route yes am i yeah / Thomas
Jeff got up